all right I think we'll do one more
segment and I'm actually not gonna lead
with lead with the water part we're
gonna do Artemis project Oh let's talk
about that so yes this next segment has
to do with part of the state of a Union
address from Donald Trump when he said
he wanted us to push and pursue the
Artemis project which would get us I'm
just gonna paraphrase it but we're gonna
read this from the NASA website what
does Donald Trump really want he wants a
moon base which will eventually be our
launch pad to go to Mars how is that not
like the coolest thing so cool it's so
cool but you know there's so many so
into this there are so many people who
just hate the guy yeah it's like I don't
okay fine I don't care but come on man
this is awesome can we get Americans to
rally around going to Mars let's get
their lease of world together at least
Elon Musk is on building a starship I
mean right let's get the role together
to come together on these these missions
yeah check this out let's pull something
like that this is from July 25th 2019 we
do have another story that might be
interesting we can tack onto this but
let's just learn about what the Artemis
project is the NASA website says NASA is
committed to landing American astronauts
including the first women in the next
man on the moon by 2024 whoa close
awesome
through the agency's Artemis lunar
exploration program we will use
innovative new technologies and systems
to explore more of the moon than ever
before we will collaborate with our
commercial and international partners to
establish sustainable missions by 2028
and then we will use what we learn on
and around the moon to take the next
giant leap sending astronauts to Mars oh
yes please this is cool
let me let me let me I want to read this
they say why go to the moon how do we
get there we'll go through this let me
just tell you man I see a lot of these
Millennials post things where they're
like I was born too or too late to
explore the earth but too early to
explore the Stars
no you weren't first of all just because
we have satellite pictures of the earth
doesn't mean there's nothing left to
explore yeah you just have to actually
want to be an explorer but most people
don't
yeah they want people I don't they what
they want the idea of what it is maybe
but come on man you realize the early
explorers were like walking around with
you know dysentery and like no food and
they're eating rabbit yeah
and they were like thousands of miles
away from any other humans exactly yeah
one fun yeah it wasn't I mean I
understand now like if you want to go to
space you need massive and insane
resources and people can do it or the
broquet men philip you fill up your
knapsack take all your supplies and go
walk through the junk the undiscovered
you know unexplored regions of the
Amazon or whatever should we should we
read about why we are going to the moon
yeah let's do that so they ask why go to
the moon will the artment well with the
Artemis program we will demonstrate new
technologies capabilities and business
approaches needed for future exploration
including Mars establish American
leadership and a strategic presence on
the moon while expanding our us a global
economic impact broaden our commercial
and international partnerships inspire a
new generation encourage careers in stem
yes are we gonna mine the moon is there
anything there I hope not no I mean how
crazy mining asteroids makes sense to me
but now have you seen the expense yeah
awesome show yeah that's cool it's like
a reality that could possibly happen
yeah you know and it's like we're out in
the solar system mining like water from
asteroids and that makes sense we're
gonna need water from something yeah on
the moon by 2025 but what's there
there's a lot of stuff here that what is
on that because isn't the moon a big
chunk of the earth well let's all read
while you look things up how do we get
there NASA's powerful new rocket the
Space Launch System will send astronauts
aboard the Orion spacecraft nearly a
quarter million miles from Earth to
lunar orbit astronauts will dock Orion
at the gateway and transfer to a human
landing system for expeditions to the
surface of the Moon they will return to
the orbital outpost to board Orion again
before we're in it returning safely to
earth do you think they're gonna be
working with Elon and SpaceX yet well
aren't they already doing it like isn't
isn't he already sending supplies to the
International Space Station yeah but I
mean this feels like they're trying to
like do it on their own did you ever see
that tweet I sent to Elon Musk no so oh
I heard about it yeah for just ID I was
just bored and I tweeted at Elon Musk
hey at Elon Musk why haven't you built
yourself an Iron Man suit yet and he
responded working on Star
and I got all excited I phone started
vibrating like crazy and I'm like what
is this like I got a good amount of
followers okay so I get notifications
but this was nuts yeah and so then I
looked and I see you responded and I was
all excited I responded this is an
acceptable response and I was like no
made my week made my month I was like so
cool still thought would happen but it
also was like I think genuinely cool
that Elon kind of engages that way yeah
because even something silly like that I
think was probably inspirational to a
lot of people true I was joking I'm like
dude healing muscle super rich she
should make an Ironman suit you know
it's crossed his mind oh for sure
Ironman suit but but now he's he's
actually building a starship yes and
jokes like that I think will inspire
people you know one of the one of the
greatest things that happened to America
was the space race the country came
together with this great mission this
unifying force and right now we're so
divided and everyone hates each other
the challenge is there are a lot of
people who don't care about any of this
stuff
in fact they hate it I think it was more
than just America - it was like we were
racing against another country and it
wasn't an arms race in this sense he was
an inspiration yeah it was like we're
trying to kind of the moon we're trying
to and they were working together in
some senses you know like and then we've
actually used Russia's rockets to get
into space oh there was ask you know
whoever knows how long there was a cool
it so there was a fear that if we didn't
together get access to space they would
have weapons that surpassed us right and
then they could attack us right so that
makes sense that it is basically an arms
race so we talk about right but but
there was so much that inspired the
country when everyone you know wants to
watch the moon landing all that stuff
yeah that it it inspired people to
become engineers and stuff what's
interesting is the age yeah of NASA's
engineers today I think back then it was
like in the twenty they were in their
20s and today it's like they're in their
40s yeah because like people don't want
to work there people don't want to be
you know this discovers of new worlds
and you know new realms or whatever I
think one of the big challenges is our
technology we use physical hard fuels
yeah for propulsion and there's limits
to how much weight and and how fast you
can go maybe we won't ever get
interspatial like warp drive or anything
like that
but we really got it we get we really
have to figure out how to travel faster
than we can understand right now yeah
well it didn't a solar sail work like
the first one blew up and then really
yeah they they brought out the second
one last year sometime and it works I
don't know it's low there is like some
crazy engine I was reading about where
it's like a self-contained propulsion to
the M Drive is that what it is where it
fires like photons yeah yeah I know the
back creating minor just a little tiny
bit yeah but it is propulsion right yeah
so yeah it's an internal engine that's
so weird I've but we but I think maybe
the problem right now is we we're we're
essentially like you know the Pacific
Islanders with little boats you know we
don't have these big frigates and
galleons to take us yeah on the high
seas you know like the deserts are yeah
maybe or maybe once the Artemis project
gets launched and we're on the moon yeah
we then have a way to start ferrying you
know resources well if we start building
it in space then we're not gonna have to
exactly gravity exactly right so even if
we're on the moon escaping the moon is a
lot easier right
so we're basically there and that's why
we go from Mars so I don't know if you
have you guys seen at Astra I haven't
seen it yet I thought it was really good
okay I'll check it out but it's
definitely not for everybody okay cuz
it's very slow but it was cool to see
how like the moon port looked like an
airport that's like I think that they
have like a Hardee's and like you know
Hard Rock Cafe or whatever yeah well
it's an you sure though it looks like an
airport yeah and they treat it like one
and then there's like dark zones with
like space bandits literally like people
on Rover is you know trying to steal
stuff and like like pirates cool
but then that's that but in the movie
that's what they do they you go to the
moon first and then you go to Mars and
it's like very early on relatively in
the Mars colony okay but man if there's
anything I'd hope for its that the
mission of the world and all of the
people would be to colonize Mars to make
it to the stars to build better
technology and stop fighting over things
that make no they don't matter
yeah but I'll tell you wonderful but
here's the problem right there are
people in this country in this world
that are mad
at Elon Musk why would you waste money
on a spaceship to go to Mars when you
could pay for the health care of people
because they don't realize what what
NASA's talking about is that a lot of
technology we take for granted was
developed in the space race was
developed by this kind of research and
spacefaring research kind of stuff yeah
so yeah we're gonna look that money's
still gonna be spent here it's gonna go
in the economy and we're gonna develop
new technologies there to make life
better for everybody right but more
importantly what's your life mission
they don't have one it's just to live
and be angry at other people and be and
and and and morally outraged for me my
mission is to expand you know humanity
it's it's kind of like it's it's tough
you know I didn't grow up and go to
school and become an astronaut and try
and push you many to the stars but I
certainly want to make sure that that's
a function of what we do I want to go on
flossed in Paradise you know what I'm
talking about Fifth Element what it's
the space cruise oh yeah yeah you know
what I mean where they flip over they're
like we're gonna go to the other side of
the planet and just flip over and so you
get a beautiful view of it yeah yeah
sunsets like yeah I want to go on a
space I just I just saw this movie after
out it's called but they're going on a
trip I think to Mars I think I can't
remember and they're in this massive
ship and they get an unexpected asteroid
collision and they use a massive burst
of fuel to dodge it which puts them off
course okay and then they're gone and
they don't have enough fuel to turn
around so they just get going and it's
like the movie takes place over how like
this this ship which was not meant to be
yeah it was like people spent their life
there yeah it's a movie okay and I think
it might be in a different language I'm
not sure okay yeah I'm out maybe yeah I
think so sounds cooler out it's called
it's on Hulu I think and then basically
it's sad movie I'm gonna spoiler alert
for anybody who actually might end up
wanting to see it but they they never
make it back and then the movie ends
where it's like 65 million years later
and the ship is just a ghost ship yeah
and it's full of like loading along just
just just like decay like nothing inside
yeah and it makes it to an earth-like
planet and just like sorry I think it
like just they just show it pulling up
yeah it's
it's it's scary it's creepy they're
doing like a comedy show kind of like
this really where they're on a yeah I
swear to god it's gonna be like an HBO
or something where they're on a big
space vessel that gets knocked off
course yeah
like it's made by the people who do veep
or something I'm so yes yeah cool
all right let's read a let's read a
little bit a little bit more about what
we're gonna do and then we'll wrap this
one up first of all they say we will get
there they say well we're seeing 2021
ahead of the human return we will send a
suite of science instruments and
technology demonstrations to the lunar
surface through commercial moon
deliveries beginning in 2021
that is amazing that's next year the
agency will fly to missions around the
moon to test its deep-space exploration
systems NASA is working toward launching
Artemis one an uncrewed flight to test
the SLS and Orion spacecraft together
followed by the Artemis to mission the
first SLS and Orion test flight with
crew NASA will land astronauts on the
moon by 2024 on the Artemis 3 mission
about one year thereafter I'm sorry man
this is hatch Trump Trump called for
this and called for us to push forward I
will absolutely support his endeavor in
this regard as cool what will we do
there find a new so this is wait wait
well Mars remains our Horizon goal yes
we we have set our sights first and
exploring the entire surface of the Moon
with human and robotic explorers we will
send astronauts to new locations
starting with the lunar South Pole at
the moon we will find and use water and
other critical resources needed for
long-term exploration investigate the
moon's mysteries and learn more about
our home planet in the universe learn
how to live and operate on the surface
of another celestial body where
astronauts are just three days from home
prove the technologies we need before
sending astronauts on missions to Mars
which can take up to three years
round-trip Wow do you have what it takes
for a three-year trip no and you're
probably gonna be with only a couple
people now I'm not going to Mars I don't
want to go to Mars I read that they want
couples to do it oh really
yeah that makes sense and I think I
think if it's just really makes sense
yeah you know I like I every seen the
movie passengers with um yeah Jennifer
Lawrence Pratt I never finished it
actually I'm I'd be willing to say if
you were in a relationship with somebody
and it was the only other person no
matter what happened
you'd probably still find a way to
always get back together because you
literally have no choice and you'd go
insane in solitary confinement yeah I
don't like movies where it's just like
not telling the truth and that's the
plot twist right like oh I just didn't
tell you it's like almost everybody
learn movie right can't somebody but
somebody did a rillette it or they said
if you take act two and make it act one
it becomes way better interest if the
movie starts with Jennifer Lawrence
waking up uh-huh
and you don't know what a crisp as crap
yes we've been better you're right
because then you're not in your in your
in the mystery you don't know what
happened yeah I've probably been much
more then it show it goes back to show
you what he really did yeah yeah there
would've been way better yeah
well I'll tell you this I certainly
believe a mission to Mars will not be
like the movie passengers but that's a
three year trip how long do you think it
is until we see like a McDonald's arch
on the moon I don't know I don't know
because you know your big old billboard
floating in the sky for all of humanity
to see it's like the best billboard but
why would it be McDonald's I had to just
make it subway who's making it your
subway there's more Subway's there isn't
there there are more Subway's there more
sub wasn't McDonald's I really thought
you'd say chick-fil-a no I mean they're
doing reticulate is doing really well
but alright all these TV shows they're
always like what was I just watching
where I was like the year's 2020 and it
showed like a space mission I cameras
from like the 90s or whatever yeah I
love that the 2022 like this air was
abominable
far into the future I'm like what did we
accomplish we got angry people on social
media yelling about you know where's the
flying car he's the chicken shop I want
the flying cars it's like we were
promised no I don't I take that back we
were proud people suck at driving so we
were promised hoverboards and clothes
that would resize themselves and shoes
that would tie themselves and what do we
get
well I can't say this Nike did make
those shoes didn't they yeah yeah no
they're real wait wait they made them
they're expensive but I I can I can't
say one thing I did not make this up I
got it off the internet somewhere what
we did get was a device that we can hold
it we can put in our pockets that
contains or gives us access to the
summation of human knowledge that's
pretty I use it to look at pictures of
cats and argue with strangers on the
Internet
great humans you did a great job now how
about we go to Mars oh yeah let's do it
let's go we'll wrap this up here well
we'll grab the remaining super chats and
then I'm gonna pass out because I got
very little sleep we were building sound
engineering stuff so and I'm staying up
till like you know 12:30 last night
waking up at 6 a.m. we're belong every
music room it's gonna be sweet plus we
got trees planted and stuff there's a
lot of work to expand because we're
gonna be using the outdoor area for a
ton of other stuff scooty yeah there's
probably gonna be another channel coming
up soon because I how long do you think
I'm tall just like drop dead from like
exhaustion and then you know you guys
long beanie charge you'll be good yeah
every night I have to plug it in it's
all--it's we're good alright okay where
were we at with these super jets doo doo
doo doo doo thanks for checking out this
segment from the Tim cast IRL podcast we
do the show every Monday through Friday
at 8 p.m. sometimes an hour or two and
we do have a full live recorded version
of the show that includes a lot of
comments and smaller segments you
probably don't see if you want to check
that out you can watch live at 8 p.m.
Monday through Friday or become a member
of this channel and for five bucks a
month you get full access to all of the
recorded podcasts every day after the
show we make them available in the
community section of this YouTube
channel so don't forget to subscribe and
stick around for more segments and more
shows Monday through Friday at 8 p.m.
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the next show
you